even when I watch sports today I see
these guys on the Range yeah like
they're all buddies and their caddies
are friends and that's not the Killer
Instinct
[Music]
you know I always said we played for the
name
Jersey was a Patriots or the bucks or
anyway I played for the name on the back
of the Jersey which is
I think you've chosen the enemy's wise
man I'm gonna play ten more years
it takes so many
people to get to where we get
about work ethic I learned about
resilience I learned about gaining the
trust and the respect that my teammates
and coaches to name me Captain just like
in your business
every year is different
you motivate me I didn't think about any
of it
foreign
[Applause]
I can't wait for you to watch this
interview with Tom Brady by the way from
the moment he walked in he was in charge
comfortable respectful loose and you'll
sense it the moment you watch it he
walked in Dylan's like hey Tom I want to
throw the ball with you he said well
then let's go they go to the back of the
hotel where there's a wide open place at
the Diplomat and they start throwing the
ball and then he's running grouts with
Dylan and then he's running routes with
my oldest son Patrick and then he says
so Dad you're gonna run or what like
he's almost like pushing you challenging
you you could feel his leadership from
the second he got there and then when he
hits the stage super comfortable super
loose I even asked him why are you so
comfortable and loose right now like
what caused you to be this slow you'll
sense that and then there was a couple
things we talked about I asked them
about you know winning seven
championships was it more important for
him to win seven because having one more
than Belichick or one more than uh
Michael and you'll be the judge of which
one mattered most I give my assumption
on which one I thought it was but his
Focus how he drove his people how
different it was with everybody else all
in all this is by far one of the most
unique interviews I've ever done and
timely the fact that this is after his
career being done so he was a little bit
more comfortable to talk versus a Tom
Brady that's typically like well we had
a game today I take responsibility as a
quarterback we have to come back and
watch a tape that's not the time you're
going to see a complete different time
in this interview with them so with that
being said here's Tom Brady Tom Brady
when we pulled up records there's so
many of them let me just read some of
them here for you most games won by
player 251 most games played by a
non-kicker 335. most games start at 3
333 division titles most career passing
yards 89 000 214. most career pass
completions 7 700 attempts touchdowns
most Courier passing yards with one team
I mean I can go over and he's beating
every single team in the NFL one of only
four people to do it it was so wild in
our family everybody was required to
watch man in the arena everybody all my
kids that aren't to go back catching the
ball with them they're enamored by him
because they've watched man in the arena
over and over and over again my daughter
watched it my wife watched it Tico watch
it Dylan watch it we ran it at Foxboro
Stadium we brought Ben his manager one
of his best friend coupled the guys I
played with them were in there watching
man on the arena again to kind of feel
the emotion of what it was like playing
with a guy like this being a teammate
with a guy like this maybe coaching
somebody like this and you know as a guy
that's a fan of the sport I've never
played organized Sports okay I didn't
play in high school I didn't do any of
that stuff but I'm a fan I'm coming
purely from a fan
there are certain players that we have
to ask
can anyone ever do this again
so for example Wilt Chamberlain 100
points I don't know
home runs 74 in a season I don't know
is somebody going to go out there and do
this or beat Gretzky's record or beat
that
I don't know if there's gonna be another
player to play for as long as he did and
win seven super bowls and break all the
records that may not happen in our
lifetime now we all believe in doing the
impossible but he made it so hard for
somebody else to want to replicate it's
almost like he emotionally got everybody
else that's behind him trying to catch
up to him say dude there's everybody
else I can compete with then there's Tom
set Tom aside I'm going to go after this
guy there's no way I'm going to be Tom
so this is a one of a kind of a
one-of-a-kind type of a person you'll
see the painting at the end when we give
him as a gift there's some special
messages in there we'll give them I
consider this guy
the goat of goats please stand up and
give it up to the one and only Tom pray
day
[Applause]
it is
[Music]
nice to be with you guys
house
are we fired up or what
[Applause]
that's a little better
Tom are you naturally we're not going to
the stadium to get all fired up so this
is kind of cool to be with you guys
thank you very much Patrick for allowing
me to be here and um it's now kind of my
hometown I've been bounced around to a
lot of different places over the years I
grew up in California went to school in
the midwest played in Boston for 20
years and then in Tampa so I've traveled
around a little bit and um I feel like
I've gotten to know a lot of people over
the years and obviously I love being in
front of groups of people sharing some
of the amazing insights that I've had
over a lot of years in competitive
Sports and teamwork and discipline and
success and probably a lot of things
that you guys are looking to achieve in
your career so it's a pleasure to be
with you guys I know um what day is this
out of the four days that you've this is
the second to the last day tomorrow's
the last day okay so one last day
tomorrow so hope you guys are doing the
work and listening and paying attention
hopefully I can provide you guys with a
couple little nuggets to take with you
on your own personal Journeys
so first of all it's great to have you
here okay I know you're uh humble about
it but we're honored to have you here uh
uh are you always this fired up like
even back when we were you were leading
everybody back there like you're telling
me what to do you're telling Dylan what
are you always like that I think if you
roll the football out there man I know
what to do I got you and your son
brought one around the corner and
there's only one thing you know it's
like when you're a kid I always think
it's you're pretty lucky in life if you
know you learn as a kid to like bounce a
ball or dribble a ball and you don't
have to be obviously be a professional
at it but some things in life can be
pretty simple if you like you know
bouncing a ball or hitting a ball or
kicking a ball and um I think that's
very much the way that I was a lot like
you know your sons are back there and
everyone finds their own interests I was
so fortunate to find a real love for
sports and it wasn't just you know
hitting the ball throwing the ball it
was the camaraderie of teammates and um
there's so many things that I've learned
over the years being a part of a team
setting and being involved in sports and
dealing with people and relationships
and yeah it's about getting the ball in
the end zone but
that's uh that that that's the final you
know step in the process there's so many
other things that lead to the
camaraderie and the
um
the ability to do that more often than
most other teams so that's really where
the work is yeah I was watching you back
there you're you're you're telling Dylan
so Dylan what are you going to do let's
warm up you're throwing the ball okay
what route you're gonna run boom hot
hike no step back that's yours we got
this okay why don't you play defense on
him Hey Dad are you gonna go you're
putting everybody to work it was
interesting watching you do that but
what was that first moment for you for
these kids they're going to be 40 years
old one day saying I freaking God
Brady's pass at nine years old life
changing for these guys what was that
moment for you when you were a kid yeah
that's a little bit about inspiration
and for me I I grew up in very fortunate
I grew up in San Mateo California which
was just south of San Francisco
yeah at a time when the San Francisco
49ers were the team in the NFL and um I
grew up in a very Sports Centric family
I had three older sisters who I always
say we're all better athletes than I
ever was and I was just like their Punky
brat little brother that would follow
them to their softball games at night at
our basketball games and always cheered
them on and my Dad loved Sports my mom
loves sports and it was just very much a
part of our family so so many of the
memories that I had as a kid were
growing up on Sports Fields going to the
batting cage at night with my dad I was
the youngest of four so
um we would always sneak off to the golf
course when we wanted to have some boy
time and and I learned just so many
lessons I think from from those early
ages being in my own family and being
with sisters that were supportive of me
my mom and then ultimately I grew up on
a street where there were you know it
was just a normal street in the Bay Area
there was 60 70 kids on the street we
played this one we used to play in this
Street you know a lot of people in here
probably played in the street too but
this was go down and make a right at the
fire hydrant and you know go right at
the white car oh don't get hit by the
truck coming down you know and the car
would come and everyone would back off
so it was just a normal way to grow up
and I think that uh that was just such a
great way for me to grow up in the Bay
Area with a love for football and a love
for Sports in general but to grow up on
a street where that's what we did we
played football two-hand touch in in the
street there were no we didn't have much
of a front yard you know we played if
you hit the curb that was out of bounds
so growing up it was just so normal for
me and I really in a way still feel my
life is like that I don't feel like I've
changed much over the years in terms of
what my values were what my priorities
were
um I just had those inspirational
moments I'd say from growing up in the
Bay Area and idolizing Joe Montana and
Steve Young Who are my sports idols and
in baseball you know Barry Bonds went to
my high school he's one of the greatest
baseball players of all time
um so there was these Sports Idols I had
that really inspired me to dig deeper
with myself and and I found a lot of
people over the way uh over 46 years to
support me in this journey Tom was there
was there a moment where you're like did
you have a moment like that with Montana
threw a past that you or Steve Young
through a passage and if yes how old
were you and outside of that when you
first met him were you in your mind at
all sizing them up or you were just
enamored I cannot believe I'm catching a
ball from a guy like this yeah well I
never caught any passes from anyone but
what I did do was I I was a bat boy an
honorary batboy at a San Francisco
Giants baseball game and I was sitting
in the Dugout and there was a great
left-handed hitter who was one of my
favorite players Will Clark his name was
will the grill and he uh he was my you
know at that time the Giants he was my
favorite player and he came out of the I
was sitting in the Dugout just scared
shitless you know not saying a word
looking straight ahead and he came out
from the tunnel the clubhouse and came
up and he was saying something and like
a squeaky voice where's another Helmet
or something like that and I just
sunk back on my seat and my dad was like
say something say something I was like
I'm not saying anything
and then finally I stood up and I said
you know Mr Clark I'm Tom nice to meet
you and I said Tommy this is Tommy nice
to meet you and he said nice to have you
kid and you know it was one of those
moments where it was kind of really
eye-opening for me and um
you know I had this opportunity I was
young to play but I was actually a
pretty good baseball player when I was
when I was a kid and um
I was just surrounded by all those
Sports and I I picked a high school
where it was very uh it was right down
the street from my house but it was very
baseball type school and California
where I grew up it wasn't really focused
on football there wasn't a ton of that
it was more baseball focused so but
either way there was a lot of sports and
you know Sports in all of our
communities were pretty impactful and
influential in the ways that you know we
grew up and we and we socialized and you
know again I was fortunate to grow up at
a great time in in football sports in
the Bay Area did you always like if I
was in high school with you uh 13 14 15
years old did you always have an
absolute Killer Instinct where I'm gonna
show you I'm going to prove the way to
see what I'm going to do I'm going to
kill this guy when we face him was it
always like that when you were in high
school or that kind of developed later
on yeah I think it developed over a
period of time and I think there was a
work ethic that was in me
um
I think most people probably know a few
things about me but I was never I would
say like a prodigy you know I wasn't
like the kid where you see Tiger Woods
swinging on the Johnny Carson show at
two or three years old and you know his
swing looks as good as it did at three
years old as it did you know as he as he
grew older or you know certain players
that had that had this unbelievable uh
Prodigy aspect to themselves I I saw
myself as someone who probably had some
other traits that maybe were hard to
identify but that were really
sustainable over time which was I would
say work ethic and and discipline and
that was instilled in Me by I think my
parents I mean there was part of it that
they gave me but also just behaviorally
growing up in an environment where my
dad was out there out to work every
morning you know trying to go make a
living for our family and my mom woke up
every day trying to figure out how to
make sure the home was comfortable for
us and you know to support the kids so
there was this discipline that I had
that even as 13 14 15 years old where
all these other boys is where I went to
an all-boy School in the Bay Area and I
remember showing up my first day as
freshman year I didn't have much you
know hair under my arms or anything like
that I was like and these other kids
came in shaving and I'm like what the
hell is this I didn't know how to put
the pads on in my pants when I tried out
for freshman football I mean I had never
played until that point except in the
streets so these kids came out there
they had you know helmets and shoulder
pads that they had worn for four years
through Pop Warner and I went on the
field and I was like I'm gonna get
killed out here you know and my freshman
year I didn't even play I was the backup
quarterback on a team that went 0-8
that says a lot
I couldn't get on the field and we never
won a game anyway
I mean it's one thing to be the starting
quarterback in the lose if they don't
even think you're good enough to be a
starting quarterback on a team that's on
it you must really suck
and the reason why I played my second
year was because
that quarterback quit because he was
like I'm not playing football anymore we
suck I'm gonna focus on basketball so
naturally I was like oh cool I'll
continue to you know work on my skill
because I actually had a halfway decent
arm but a lot of it was even going into
my second year in high school
there were workouts in the morning at 6
a.m before school and I was like okay I
can I can get up at 6am and I can go do
these rope drills where you'd run
through the ropes see a lot of people do
that there were these Hills that we
would run up and there was probably less
than 10 people there but I was probably
one of the three that were there almost
every single day to try to continue to
push myself to grow in these maybe
physical areas that I was really behind
a lot of other people at because
naturally no one's good at everything I
mean that's just not the way life Works
we're all talented at certain things but
we can really continue to improve our
weaknesses if we're humble enough to
identify them and we can build on our
strengths and I think we're all trying
to find a more well-rounded aspect to
ourselves but a lot of that has to come
with this this understanding about
yourself that what you know is very
limited and what you don't know is
Limitless and you have an opportunity
every day to surround yourself up with
people to help you grow and that could
be in my case it very much was my
parents early on and then as I learned
to love the sport of football yeah I was
watching kind of on the periphery of pro
athletes but there was a high school
there was a junior college football
coach that I wanted to become a better
Pastor because I had a good arm and he
was a three-sport coach at a junior
college his name was Tom Martinez one of
my great mentors and he coached women's
softball which is how it really I knew
him women's basketball and men's
football
and I would go up there and I would go
up there to his Camp to to learn to
throw the ball better when I was in 14
years old 15 years old and it just
became this like I said life was pretty
simple when you could kick a ball or
throw it and that for me it was throwing
it and I wanted a throat ball better so
who better than to find this guy who was
probably ahead of his time as a coach
and he taught me how to throw the ball
uh with some good fundamentals and I
really saw that it's like wow I can go
see someone who has more knowledge than
me and I can learn from him and I can
take him back to my school and
everyone's going to go wow Tom you made
some improvements and I think that was a
good learning experience for me even at
a young age so it wasn't it wasn't the
uh you know because there's a couple
different ways that you it happens right
like in the in business world you're
trying to do the business you get into
real estate Insurance technology
whatever it is and then all of a sudden
you're like let me see if I can make
money with this thing then it's kind of
like oh my God this is actually great
and then you kind of size yourself up
against other people are like wow I
think I can actually beat that guy and
who is the guy that does it this well
let me go to that guy oh wow I didn't
know about this it's kind of like we
were telling the story about Hernandez
but when when was it like when was it
where you said no I think I can play
against everybody because even in
college if you think about the two Drews
in your life right yeah
you're you're in Michigan you got what
Brian Griese I believe right and then
Drew of low yeah and then you got Drew
Hansen who becomes a like you he was
also a baseball player too he ended up I
think getting drafted by the Yankees by
Johansson and and it was an interesting
structure to coach had one quarter one
quarter you know two quarters two
quarters first half second half which is
kind of tough to create momentum I think
you guys went 21 and 5 or 20 and five or
something like that with the record you
had and then so but you were like a
backup to Drew and then comes Drew
Bledsoe back up to Drew again so there's
a backup are you in your mind saying
where the market kind of like the movie
Sea Biscuit yeah you're just a horse to
help the other guy get better you're not
the horse that's supposed to be the
number one horse so you always train to
kind of be here to build the confidence
the other guy that's going at what point
did you say these guys have no freaking
clue who the hell I am I'm a number one
guy did that ever click in your mind
where you were number two saying I
belong being number one well I think
there was a naturally a very competitive
part of me and
I love that and I can I go back a little
bit of course give you a little context
too so my freshman year in football I
didn't I didn't even play literally
didn't play maybe two or three passes
the coach furnace sideline screamed at
me one time my freshman year Brady
you're moving in slow motion
and um I was a man I was slow as
still still am
so going into my second year I I like I
said the guy quit ahead of me so I
became the junior varsity quarterback
there were three teams in my high school
and I had a coach named Bob vinell Perry
Carter Joe Hessian at Sarah high school
and they were there for the football
experience they were having as much fun
as the kids were they didn't see it as
varsity football they were there to
embrace the Love of the Game and for the
kids that weren't good enough to play on
varsity and they really took me under
their wing and we had so much fun that
second year I love my football
experience one of the great years of my
entire life
I really started working hard with Tom
Martinez to throw the ball better my
third year I won the starting job in my
high school
and I love this sport so much that I
stopped playing basketball and I just
played baseball and football but in the
Summers I would go and my dad who was
very available to me with the greatest
Mentor the greatest dad I could ever
imagine was so right there by my side to
say Hey Dad I want to be better football
player great let's take you to the
University of Arizona Camp let's take
you to the Cal Berkeley Camp let's take
you to uh the Stanford Camp you know
this is when you just sign up and
there's a thousand other kids and you're
just in a group and you know that's just
the way it was but my dad was there to
say go for it son and if there was a
blessing in my life that I would say you
know some of the things I blessed with
hard work discipline you know I was also
blessed with being very naive
I had no idea how hard it was and but I
believed because I was like I don't know
like I'm I'm gonna get better and I'm
gonna I'm gonna be better well going
into my fourth year in high school I was
recruited but not like a lot of the top
kids there was look I was big I was the
size I am now tall I had a good arm but
there were a lot of other physical
deficiencies that they saw so I wasn't a
high recruit so I had there was and it
was a different era where look we're in
the digital age now that's not the way
things work back in 1994. we had to make
VCR tapes with my dad in his office when
I said Dad we gotta like put together
the most clips that I have and this is
when my dad would film the games I mean
now it's like Channel 5 broadcast every
High School game in the area like this
was my dad with a camcorder and every
time the ball was thrown he'd be focused
on me right and the ball would go this
way and he'd stand up and the camera
would go to the left and he'd be
watching and he'd start jumping out go
so of course we miss like every
important throw that I in high school
so we pieced together enough enough
Clips to like go hey man where get Tommy
where do you think you want to go to
college and I was like I don't know like
University of Illinois and I was looking
at a lot of like maybe not top tier
College programs and in the end I was
like well yeah just let's send one to
USC let's send one to Michigan and I was
like do you think we should send one to
Michigan dad and he's like yeah may as
well you know you think you like it of
course I'm from California you know I
didn't Michigan that's a long way from
California
so
I send these tapes out and there's a
little bit of Buzz about me and I start
getting recruited and I get these
letters and of course I'm like
wow get every day I'm getting these
different letters from school saying oh
you know you we consider you a prospect
continue to keep up the good work and I
would file them all you know in a file
folder and my cup my high school
counselor came up to me he's like Tom we
got to start applying to colleges and
I'm like dude I'm getting a scholarship
what are you talking about and he's like
yeah no we're going to apply to all
these colleges
and um
funny story I never applied to any
college
but I actually got halfway decent
through my fourth year in college that
the the momentum picked up and I wanted
to go I got offered a scholarship to
UCLA
and then they turned me away at the last
minute because another kid signed before
me and I really wanted to go to USC that
was probably my first choice but
they didn't want me either they signed
another kid who was one of the top
recruits on the west coast so I never
forget these stories by the way these
are like hardcore ingrained so then
I went to Michigan I show up
they walked me into the big house
and it's called the big house for a
reason there's a hundred and two
thousand people in there on a college
football Saturday now it's expanded like
112 000 it's incredible and I walked
through the tunnel at Midfield and they
go from Sarah High School in San Mateo
Tom Brady and I looked up and I was like
I want to go to school here
so I'm there for two days I don't talk
to my parents the whole time you know we
didn't have cell phones and I get to the
airport in Detroit and I call my dad
collect and I go Dad I think I know
where I want to go to college and like
he started breaking down and he's like
what you know leaving to to go all the
way back to Michigan and he said are you
sure you want to go and I said Dad if I
want to be the best I gotta beat the
best and this is where the best are so I
showed up on campus as a freshman in the
spring in the fall of 1995. I was the
seventh quarterback on the depth chart
there were six other guys ahead of me
and Michigan is a good is a great
College there's you know it's competes
for national championships and I wanted
to be a great football player if I was
gonna be a great football player I
wanted to compete against these other
guys and they were all better than me
like like I said just like in high
school I was deficient well I was
we had another athlete who was in my
freshman class at Michigan Charles
Woodson
and Charles showed up on campus he had a
goatee he looked like a Greek god
and I was like how am I in the same
locker room as this guy this guy looks
like a physical freak which he was and
he won the Heisman in his third year and
he went on to be a Hall of Famer in the
NFL and he's one of my great friends but
we laugh because man that freshman
locker room I'm looking over there at
like Charles Woodson as the seventh
quarterback and Charles out there
starting on opening day as a true
freshman and I I I was you know worked
really hard because I developed this
work ethic in high school and I realized
man if I want to be good I gotta I gotta
wake up in the morning I gotta do the
extra work and I gotta show up when
other guys aren't and I've got to learn
I've got to continue to be open to
learning and my freshman year I
redshirted
never played barely practice but I
learned a lot my second year I had
improved a lot physically through that
work and
I started to compete in a way that would
the coaches would notice me a little bit
and
my second year it was a few little crazy
stories but of how it got to be the way
that it did but I ended up becoming the
third quarterback in my second year
and
it rotated a little bit there my second
year but I went from third in my second
year to now my third year I was
competing to be a starter
and because I learned to compete in high
school and I learned to compete my first
two years in college in fact I almost
thought about leaving Michigan and in my
second year
I got a call from uh uh Steve Mariucci
at Cal and he said Tom if you come here
you can start for us and you're going
into your third year if you leave
Michigan you can come here and you can
start for us and of course Cal was one
of my great choices I thought I
could go home and be a starter
and I walked into coach Carr's office
the head coach at Michigan at the time
and I said coach like I you know what's
my situation like and he said Brady I
want you to stop worrying about what all
the other players on our team are doing
you all you do is you focus on the
starter the second guy you don't worry
about what's you're focused on you came
here to be the best I want you at this
program and if you're going to be the
best you got to beat out the best
and he goes you got to start working
with this guy named Greg Hardin who was
another Mentor in my life Greg just came
out with the book A few days ago and
Greg had been a sports psychologist at
Michigan and
like you know we got to start building
this knowledge and we got to create a
strategy and a plan and he would said
you know I would complain all the time
that the guys ahead of me were getting
more opportunity than I was there was a
certain amount of repetitions in
practice the starter would get 20. the
backup would get 10 and I would get two
and I'd go in and I'd say well how can I
ever get better all these guys get all
the Reps and I only get two and he said
just go in there and focus with the two
that you got and make them as perfect as
you possibly can so I said okay
so that's what I did they'd put me in
for those two man I'd Sprint in there
like it was Super Bowl 49. let's go boys
here we go what flight we got
and I did really well with those two
because I brought enthusiasm I brought
some energy and I had a little more
confidence in myself and it went from
two reps to getting four reps because
those two were pretty good then I had
four good reps then I got ten good reps
and before you knew it through this new
attitude through this new shift that
Greg had said to me you know focused on
what you can control focus on what
you're getting not what anyone else is
getting whenever you get an opportunity
you take advantage of you treat it like
it's the Super Bowl you treat it like
it's game day go out there and treat
practice like no one else does and I did
that every single day and there was a
lot it was taxing on me there was a lot
of stress for me even in high school and
I look back at those times it wasn't
probably like a typical college
experience because I was really
motivated to play but I had to take it
to a new level that the other guys
wouldn't
so going into my fourth year now I had
competed first off freshman year
sophomore year I'm going into my third
year and I had learned these tools to
compete and I said whatever they asked
me to do that's what I'm gonna do to the
best of my ability and I went in there I
competed really hard my third year and I
lost a starting job to Brian Griese and
Brian Griese he led the team to a 12-0
national championship that year so I was
part of a national championship team and
I barely played so I go into my fourth
year and I was like now's my time
I worked hard to compete my first three
years going into my fourth year I got a
great opportunity to play
and I worked hard it's time for me to
come
and they recruited a kid named Drew
Henson to who was one of the top
prospects in the country from
Michigan right next door to University
of Michigan and here he was coming in
the door that everyone knew about he was
on the cover of Sports Illustrated so
all the fans and all the media they
weren't they they weren't were
interested in Tom Brady backup
quarterback to Brian Griese Tom Brady
backup quarterback to Scott Dreisbach
his first year Scott driestbaka's second
year now we have Drew Henson coming in
and I was like the competitions were
Relentless at first I was looking at the
guys ahead of me now I got to be looking
down at the guys behind me too
but I said you know what I'm going to
apply the same thing that I learned in
those previous years I'm gonna go out
there and compete as hard as I can and
I'm going to treat practice like a game
and I'm going to gain the respect that
my teammates every day through my work
ethic I'm going to work hard in the
weight room I'm going to work hard in
the film room I'm gonna work hard to be
a good student and going into my fourth
year it was a little bit of a battle and
my teammates named me team captain
and I won the starting job
and
we had a good year we finished ten and
three
we in our bowl game we played in the
Citrus Bowl and we came back from a I
think it was a 10-point lead in the
fourth quarter and to win the game
and I was like man that was unbelievable
now that I'm going into my fifth year
like we're gonna have a great year
that's ten and three learned a lot you
know beat everyone out and I showed up
and Coach Carr says well you're going to
compete with Drew Henson to be the
starter going into your fifth year
and I was like you got to be
kidding me
but
I was like you want me to compete that's
what we're gonna do and Drew had
improved too so Drew is learning to
compete as well and my view on team
sports was you compete and whoever wins
the job that's the person that gets it
no one's entitled to a position on a
team whatever is best for the team
that's what everyone has to say look man
the kid beat me out he's better gives us
a better chance to win so I competed
really hard again in my fifth year took
it to a new level thought about my
conditioning my strength just thought
about how I was doing my making my
decisions off the field going to my
fifth year and I was starting to play
really good and I thought you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna have a chance
and uh coach Carr called me and he said
well Tom this is what we're gonna do
you're going to start
Drew you're going to play the second
quarter
and I'm going to decide at halftime who
plays the rest of the year
and I was like
not what I wanted to hear but I'm going
to deal with it the best way I can
so first game of the year we played
Notre Dame
I start
Drew comes in in the second quarter
he says Tom you're going to play the
rest of the game
we're down four points with two minutes
left in the game I drive him down the
field we score we win the game
I'm like man
way to go
I'm ready to ready to keep this going he
says we're going to do the same thing
next week
okay at this point is this common this
isn't like coaches do this regularly
right no it's totally it's just totally
yeah it's definitely not normal and
again I was a I was I was a team captain
too so you know I had to do I had to do
what was right by the team and I took
that that was like one of the greatest
on I always say that was one of the
great Honors that you could have was
when you're all your buddies from
college and these great athletes they
name you Captain because they say man
you deserve it we want you to be the
leader for us so
I go into you know the second game of
the year and I start Drew comes in and
he says Tom you're gonna play the third
and fourth quarter which I did we and we
won pretty handily it wasn't against a
great team so we played at Syracuse and
I played in the first quarter we didn't
score Drew came in through a touchdown
pass in the second quarter
came in and he said Drew's gonna play in
the second half
and a fifth year senior captain of the
team
ten and three won a bowl game in my
fourth year got off to an undefeated
start in my fifth year and I was like
all right let me cheer him on
I'm gonna cheer him on and we won the
game I stood up there and we sang The
Victors I sang it louder than I ever
sang after a game Hail to the victors
and I wanted my teammates to know that I
had their back even if it wasn't right
for me or I didn't feel it was right for
me
[Applause]
so we platoon for another couple games
sixth game of the year were undefeated
we're going to Michigan State
they had undefeated team I started
Drew played the second quarter
and
they started Drew in the second in the
second half
we didn't have a great third quarter
with Drew in so they brought me in
and they said Brady you're going to play
the rest of the game
almost the end of the third quarter
we scored four touchdowns
from the mid third quarter to the end of
the game
and we ended up losing
so we were five and one I walked in
there after the game all the teammates
came up said great job and Coach Carr
said
we're going to platoon next week
and I was like wow we're really in on
this platoon thing huh
we played Illinois at home we were huge
favorites I played the first quarter
Drew played the second quarter
I started the third quarter I threw an
interception he took me out of the game
they put Drew in
Drew through an interception they took
him out of the game
they put me back in
had a pretty good fourth quarter of the
game driving to win the game
our starting center in field goal
position to win I'm in the shotgun snaps
the ball 25 yards over my head
to knock us out of field out of field
goal range we lose the game to Illinois
and after that coach Carr said the
platoon's off Tom's playing the rest of
the year we didn't lose the game the
rest of the season
so
and that wasn't just because of me I
want to be really clear that was we had
a great team but what did I learn from
that whole situation you know it was a
it was a tough battle for me go it was a
tough go it was tough in high school it
was really tough in college there was a
lot of stress nothing was given to me I
didn't take the easy way out going to
Cal and saying God that could be really
easy close to home my mom can do my
laundry and everyone could come to the
game I can start I stuck it out at
Michigan where it was 10 degrees in the
winter time and it was a lot of tough
competition so of course now I'm going
to the NFL draft and I'm like get all
these Pro coaches must have seen how
good I was
I mean they watched me at Michigan we
beat Ohio State you know my senior year
I went to we played Alabama in the
Orange Bowl I threw for 340 yards in the
Orange Bowl we were down 14 points in
the fourth quarter against Alabama in
the Orange Bowl we came back in one in
overtime man I'm gonna be a second round
pick
and
you know round one two and here we go
sixth round pick 199.
and I was like
all right I'm gonna make all those other
teams pay
but what did I learn you know what did I
learn like I said I wasn't The Prodigy I
learned about work ethic I learned about
resilience I learned about gaining the
trust and the respect of my teammates
and coaches to name me Captain I learned
about how to dig deep within myself a
long way from home without a ton of
support
for the position I was in to still try
to find a way to succeed in this
situation that I really wanted to be in
because it was the best for me anyway
and here I go I get picked by the New
England Patriots and
in uh the sixth round 199 and I always
joke when they called me they said Tom
you know Hey Thomas is you know Bill
Belichick you know picking a sixth round
like we'll see him Monday like get ready
to go so to to the Patriots and there
are three quarterbacks ahead of me sound
familiar
so I was number four and Bill Belichick
kept me as the fourth quarterback in my
first year now now like there was just
cuts the other day they keep two
quarterbacks most of the time on an NFL
roster now Bill Belichick saw something
in me through watching me work a little
bit and you know watching my love for
the game all right you know we should
this kid's probably not ready to play
but you know I like him you know he's
kind of tough and you know he doesn't
look that athletic but you know he
throws the ball pretty well and he seems
to really enjoy the game so I'm gonna
keep him on the roster and um
you know that's where my Pro Journey
began so that was a long answer to your
question
look I
I think the most if I look at that
Journey from where I was as a kid
to where I was as a 22 year old I had my
parents that were in my life to support
me every step of the way I had my junior
varsity football coaches that were there
every step of the way I had my throwing
coach and Mentor Tom Martinez there
every step of the way
I went to Michigan I had coach Carr
challenge me to say those who stay will
be Champions so I stayed Greg Hardin
found a way into my life who said don't
worry about all these things are out of
your control focus on what you can do
focus on the two reps you got
I had all my teammates that supported me
I had my sisters that supported me it
takes so many people to get to where we
get in our life yeah I was there doing
some of the work but couldn't have done
if I didn't have them
so when I stand up there even sitting
here today in front of you yeah I'm I'm
just a story like everybody else it's
all just a narrative you know you have
people in your life that are there to
support you hopefully that are going to
encourage you and challenge you every
step of the way because there's no
straight line for anybody there's not a
straight line for me in this path people
kids May sit here and your kids may say
God oh Tom Brady you know God he was
able to win you you know I heard you
name some a great you know records that
I was very fortunate to be able to have
over a 23-year career all as I think
about is my parents I think about my
kids I think about my family I think
about Greg I think about my my best
friend and body Coach Alex I think of
the people that I work with every day so
for me I just am represent
representation of all these people that
have come into my life and I felt very
motivated to you know I always said we
play for the name on the front of our
Jersey was the Patriots or the bucks or
and what played for the name on the back
of the Jersey which was my family and
the people that encouraged me so that
was a great
that was that was a great first you know
22 years of my career uh in my life and
I got to the Patriots and you talked
about that one moment where I said wow I
can really do this so think about it I
had been in all this competition at
Michigan I had Brian Griese ahead of me
lead us to a national championship I had
one of the top recruits in the country
Drew Henson and I was staring those guys
down every day here I come to the
Patriots and I get drafted and I'm
fourth on the depth chart and I finally
see Drew Bledsoe throw the ball for the
first time and in my very naive
competitive way because he signed a
10-year 100 million dollar contract with
the New England Patriots when I was
making 185 thousand dollars I looked at
him and I go I could throw I could throw
the ball better than that
but that was the only one on the field
who saw that and I wasn't but I had a
belief that I could if I worked the same
way and if I gain the trust and respect
of my teammates in the same way that if
I ever did get that position and I told
this to my best best friend who was one
of my roommates in college I said if
they ever put me on the field they're
never going to take me off the field and
they never did
[Applause]
foreign
's the last time September 1st you
weren't preparing for a season I mean
it's got to be you know 32 years 32
years right so here's the question why
are you so loose I've never seen you
this loose yeah why are you so
comfortable like you are I've watched a
lot of your interviews I've watched a
lot of times where you're being talked
you are like in a very comfortable loose
Place why why is this happening right
now it's kind of weird watching you
you guys understand what I'm saying or
not for sure you are so just like in a
very good place what's going on with you
well I think it's it's a lot of it's
probably maturity I think look when
you're and you maybe you guys have seen
me you know on television and talking in
front of me look in the NFL you're not
up there to like narrate the story for
the journalists you know you're like
it's not a battle per se but you're
you're there to keep your strategy from
anyone else you know so when you're I'm
not up there to get into a lot of deep
strategy because I feel like I was
giving away things to the competition a
lot so I learn and look when you're in
the Patriots for 20 years like you know
we answered
all the questions that there's fewer
words as possible and we were not trying
to give away any bit of our strategy
because it was intense competition so I
just think now at this point in my life
you know I'm here to share as much as
I've learned I was like I said I've been
I feel like I've been so blessed I'm so
grateful for all the people that have
been in my life because I couldn't have
done it without all of them all those
experiences that
we think are the hardest things in our
life to end up being the best
experiences are in our life because
if you approach it with humility and you
look inward they become the the best
opportunities for growth and learning is
there is there a part of the reason why
you may say no Pat I'm always like this
you just haven't seen me because I'm
doing the interviews when they're asking
me the question so what'd you think
about the ball that was dropped we all
made some mistakes I made some mistakes
we have to get back and watch the tapes
and we're going to figure out a way to
get better yeah we're looking forward to
playing yeah XYZ team this next Sunday
we have some work to do yeah we also you
would always like giving them for sure
right but were you always like this
behind closed doors and the reason why I
ask is the following because
um
is there any anxiety when you're by
yourself you're like I'd be playing
right now I can beat that guy I can do
this I can or are you kind of like that
chapter is so done I am fully good I am
so at peace I am so fulfilled I got so
many other things I want to tackle I'm
done done and you're the way you are now
yeah very much so I think it's a lot
like that I feel like uh I did my part
you know I I ran a lot of marathons and
it's not that I wouldn't love to still
do it I mean I'd love to throw the
football I'm gonna probably throw the
football for as long as I could but I
also know that
you know I don't know if how many it's a
good analogy because a lot of people do
run but man it's great to run the first
probably four miles of the marathon and
it's really fun to cross the finish line
but man those middle miles probably
really stuck and if you want to be good
at those middle miles
you got to work really hard in the whole
off season to prepare yourself for a
real big challenge which is the NFL
season and you know I have a 16 year old
son I have a 13 year old son and a 10
year old girl and you know they've
they've been to enough of my games and
you know I want to be at their games and
I want to be there for them and
um you know it's a very intense season
and you know it's just a different
chapter in my life I was really I was
the oldest guy in the league like for
the last three or four years you know I
was like and and it's not that I didn't
have the ability to still relate to
those guys I still feel like I could go
out there and play at a high level but I
just you know they they need someone
that's going to be in it year round and
I think for me that commitment's too
much because my kids need me year round
too and
um you know that's the most
you know very important thing
Tom I uh I had our guys run some numbers
here so here's what we have college
football players of all time in the
history of America how many kids I play
for college football any level of
college 5.62 million kids I played
college football wow 25 000 is NFL which
means roughly
.0045 make it to the NFL out of the 25
300 Hall of Fame
.012 okay then you have the guy that
makes it into the All-Star Game or the
Pro Bowl right whatever the sport is
then he got the guy that wins a
championship and it's the MVP big deal
right then he got the guy that does it
twice or three times
and then
you got the guy that keeps going and
going and going and going
and it's got seven championship
and he's already worth a ton of money
there are no more accolades that this
guy's got to get and he keeps driving so
what is the mountain you have to hit for
you to continue meaning like there's
totally challenging enough to play for
college football yeah how many guys play
college football here why put your hands
up if you play college football it's not
a lot of hands guys they're putting your
hands up for college football okay how
many here played in the NFL or got
drafted anybody here playing the NFL how
many hands do you see one person NFL
anyone else no one out of three thousand
right we're talking NFL
so for you it has to be now sometimes
people uh use this script I'm assuming
it's a script because if I had to make
that decision I'm not having the script
well you know I have to go talk to my
wife and our family and we're going to
take some time off and decide what we're
going to do next season and come up it's
a phenomenal script that everybody uses
right yeah you know deep down inside
where you're going to be doing now you
go you know you're like I'm gonna come
back because I want to get that next one
for each next hurdle and Mountain what
did it take to get you back and was that
like an evolution of making a decision
or was like no man I'm gonna go because
I don't know what interview was and one
of the if it was Edelman or if it was
Walker I think it was Edelman where
you're like hey
man imagine if you beat Montana with
five it's like this guy's not going for
Montana this guy's going for Michael for
six he wants to have seven right so did
you know that's what you're doing to be
the greatest of the greatest or was it a
process that was an evolution yeah so I
mean in a good I'm happy I was very
long-winded to give you guys a lot of
context but to think about my high
school journey and my college Journey
now I get to the pros right
and I'm the fourth quarterback my first
year
and going to my second year and I'm like
I made a lot of physical Improvement
doubled down on my work ethic now it was
a professional work commitment different
than College where College are still an
amateur now professionally you're a pro
it's different
it's your job but I would wanted to do
extra because now I had more time I
didn't have to go to class you know and
I could just focus on football so I
wanted to you know be a pro quarterback
so I had to work at it and I watched
Drew every game and I learned from him
and I watched uh John freeze and Michael
Bishop in my second year damn we signed
Damon heward to be coming here and
compete
um to be a backup and we signed a
veteran quarterback and here I am going
as the third quarterback and I said I'm
going to compete with Damon to be the
second quarterback in my second year
and I beat Damon out at the end of
training camp and Bill coach Belichick
said you know Tom's going to be the
backup Damon you're going to be third
Drew's obviously the starter so in the
second game of the year Drew Bledsoe got
hurt
and I said if I ever get put on that
field I'm never getting taken off the
field and Drew suffered a very difficult
injury internal bleeding in the hospital
you know and it was a crazy year 2001
for all of us 9 11 and you know in my
football Journey it was a it was a crazy
year we ended up you know winning the
Super Bowl that year and I had an
incredible team
but
I learned that like it wasn't I was so
motivated to be the best I could be that
it wasn't I wasn't motivated to be the
starter I wasn't motivated to to win the
Super Bowl I just was motivated to give
my best do the best with the opportunity
I got and to never let my teammates down
those were my motivations
so this is at the beginning you were
saying it's beginning and throughout
this is this is why people would say
after you know a second Super Bowl that
we won in the third Super Bowl that we
won and a fourth Superboy we we won in
2014 against Seattle
and if this Super Bowl against Atlanta
in 2016 and a sixth one against the Rams
in 2018 and then they go to Tampa
it was the same motivation money didn't
motivate me
Fame didn't motivate me I didn't give it
about any of it I always took less money
because I wanted a good team around me I
I didn't care about going to all these
different places and doing those things
I just wanted to to be my best I wanted
to go out there and the team believed in
me I didn't want to let him down every
year was different just like in your
business every year is different you
can't sit there and say God we had a
great year let's just do the same
like you don't think everyone's watching
the whole competition's watching
especially if you're good so it's one
level of discipline and I think this is
a lot like discipline and I would say
consistent discipline has been one of
those
Prodigy like strengths that I had so I
didn't have the arm that could throw the
ball 80 yards I didn't have the fourth
three speed that Michael Vick had I
didn't have the you know the size that a
lot of guys had but I did have something
inside of me that no one could see from
the outside this level of discipline
that I could accomplish something that
was really important and really special
but
[Applause]
but not let it get to my head and not to
think that I've arrived or to think that
I'm something different or better than
anyone else I just thought man we put
our mind to it we accomplished something
incredible as a team let's go do that
again wasn't that unbelievable
and the good part in football is the
next year you start right back at the
bottom
you don't start as Super Bowl champ
Kansas City Chiefs they're not the Super
Bowl champs this year they were the
Super Bowl champs last year and nobody
could take that away from them that is
theirs forever they have a banner they
have a ring it's great but it doesn't
mean anything for this year and that's
the challenge of sports that's the
challenge we all face that's the level
of discipline I I became very
disciplined with my with my body through
who this guy who I met along the ways
was Alex Guerrero for the last 21 years
my best friend body coach Mentor
everything I owe so much of My Success
to him and you know we just learned how
to treat my body a certain way so that I
could optimize my physical performance I
could do things outside of the box
because I needed my body to feel good it
was my asset
if I my body started to deteriorate I
couldn't throw the ball the way that I
wanted so a lot of people you know this
is in a lot of people can be really
consistent let's say with your diet
because it's always on people's mind
like I want to get healthy I want to
well most people can say man I want to
eat healthy for one day or I want to
exercise for one day well I want to be
more hydrated for one day
well can you do it for a week well
that's more discipline right can you do
it for a month
that's more discipline can you do it for
a year that's even more discipline
so I was so blessed to have this
discipline over a really long period of
time and to be honest people will say
now oh come on Tom don't you go out
there and just have whatever you want
now that you're done playing and I'm
like no man this is still my asset this
is still my body look at we dealt with
it covet three years ago that can
withstand the traumas that it's going to
be faced with and in football it's faced
every week you're hitting a car crash
every single week so how do I develop a
body proactively how do I think about my
health and wellness proactively so I
don't find myself in the surgeon office
at the end of the year so I don't find
myself as a 50 year old former athlete
who needs a knee replacement so those
were really important steps on my
journey because when I began to
understand how to throw the ball better
when I began to understand through coach
Belichick how to study the game more and
to be a real student of the game right
there's only a certain lifespan for
athletes everyone thinks oh as an
athlete you just have to basically
maintain this level until your body be
completely deteriorates well and I tried
to prove to everybody
guys it doesn't have to be like that you
just got to make good choices every day
as good as possible and it's I still get
people that go how did you do it I'm
like I wrote a freaking book I literally
wrote a book buy the book and I'm not
from to buy it from me but buy it
because it's good knowledge you know
like go out there I'm trying to give you
answers to the test you know this is a
lot of athletes want to maximize their
potential maximize everything you guys
want to maximize the potential and
opportunity you have in your business
well that's a lot that's a lot of
consistent discipline it doesn't it
doesn't man mean that you can have one
good month it means that you got to do a
lot a lot more right than wrong
it means you got a lot make a lot more
good choices than bad choices it means
you have to be more disciplined than not
disciplined it means you have to
surround your people with very smart
people not people that are gonna help
you think less you got to challenge
yourself not challenge yourself less
so we're all faced with those decisions
every day and you get the opportunity
just like I had the opportunity to
choose what do you want what are your
goals what are your priorities what do
you guys want to achieve you guys are
sitting here as entrepreneurs CEOs
leaders running business running
families what's the choice you get to
make every day to wake up and say all
right this is where I'm going to focus
my time and energy how disciplined are
you to maintain that routine over a
period of time and I think that will
determine your level of success
fantastic come
but the question the question the
question I ask is why do it meaning is
is it a vision you're solving for is it
like yourself hey Vision in order for me
to be able to play for XYZ years XYZ
years and I got to be healthier I got to
be liability I got to be more flexible
because I'm shooting for a goal or I'm
shooting for a vision or it's just now I
got to be ready for this year I have a
hard time believing that it's just for
one year was there a vision for you to
say if I'm gonna be the best of all time
I'm gonna need to make sure I take care
of my health I take care of your mind I
minimize the amount of distractions were
you solving for a vision or was it just
one season at a time it was one season
that time and I'll say this I never once
in my life ever said I wanted to be the
best of all time ever
I wanted to be the best I could be
period
that's all I wanted
I learned that I learned that in college
it didn't matter what the other guys
were doing it didn't powerful it
mattered what I was doing I had to look
in the mirror every night I I had a you
know for different reasons that last
year was a hard year for me one of the
hardest in my life and I printed out the
man in the glass you know the big poster
and I put it on my mirror in the
bathroom and I looked at it every single
day and I said be proud of the man in
the glass
be proud of that man that wakes up every
day and does the best that he could do
with his priorities you know and a lot
of things happen in our life you know we
all face our challenges and adversities
and we all go through things and I think
life is about dealing with a lot of
things that you didn't want to have
happen in your life whether it's your
business or whether it's sports or
whether it's personal or you know
children and like I said we all have our
unique challenges but do the best you
can do show up every day and and make
the commitment to yourself and the
people that count on you the people that
you support you and through a lot of
failures you're going to learn a lot and
you're going to hopefully be humbled
because sometimes you know you give your
best and it doesn't work and I learned
that in sports and you learn it in life
in different ways too sometimes you do
what you do you try your best you work
hard but it just doesn't in the end go
the way you want so what are you gonna
do quit
you're gonna just blame everyone else
you're gonna go in there and blame the
guy next door and blame that person and
blame the dog and he can go out there
and sleep until 10 o'clock or you're
gonna get out of bed wake up and go do
something about it learn from it and
make it better
so
stop scholar leadership right some of
these guys here they run the business so
they're the CEO they're the owner of the
company and they have a right-hand
person right so let's just say the CEO
is craft he's dealing with the coach and
then the coach has the best sales person
or the best engineer these are different
Dynamics with relationships what was
your style of leadership meaning
leadership we talked about it earlier
today is one hey you lead by example
right but that's not enough sometimes
you lead by example you're quiet you're
like you don't say anything well you got
to do more than just lead by example
yeah you got to get other people to do
things they typically wouldn't do on
their own what what style of leader were
you so if I'm a guy then I'm like hey
man I don't want to play anymore I got
two more years I want to get my check I
want to go I want to go to a different
team get my big contract and I'm done
how are you talking to me there how are
you enrolling me into me giving my best
are you asking questions are you kicking
my ass are you taking me out to dinner
are you telling me come over to the
house what was obviously from the people
that we've spoken anybody we've talked
that's been attempt teammate Tom we I've
interviewed a lot of people that are
athletes I don't know how many guys that
were the goats their teammates freaking
everybody loved them dude people love
you like teammates loved running with
you you played three different careers
you didn't have one career you you were
one of those guys that had three careers
there you played yeah but what was your
style where you kicked their ass you
challenged them yet you believed in them
what was the method you're driving your
guys yeah so a lot of it it's a great
question I think that and and this is
another probably very very important
thing in my mind is
in terms of leadership is
is
how you relate to the people that you
work with and my vision of a
relationship comes down to one word
caring
do you care about the other person
and do you collectively care about what
you're trying to achieve
the only way people are gonna feel that
they can trust you is if you care about
them so if you just see him as a
transactional relationship oh you're
just here for this time being or
well that's all they're going to give
you but I felt like I need to connect
especially as I got older I got to
connect with the young players I need a
relationship I need the ability to
relate to them they need to trust me I
need to trust them we need to be
vulnerable to one another I need to care
for them
so before I could yell at them which
believe me I yelled at a lot of people
the relationships I had with my
teammates I had I've played with guys
from all over the country
every background you know every college
and man I would I got to be just me like
you know people you would think oh man
you're you're treated a certain way
which yeah when you outside of a
building people know you they see on TV
they treat you a certain way when you're
in the building man you're just another
guy you're like you know my my son going
to camp for three weeks sleep away camp
and there's no electronics and this is
up in Maine this year there are no
electronics they sleep in like a uh like
this Log Cabin you know they swim in the
lake every morning they eat in the
cafeteria and I drive away last year and
I'm like we know we all need more of
that
and then about five minutes later I was
like well I do live that life I'm still
a football player
you know we're all in this building
where we're eating a cafeteria we're
getting mf'd by our coach you know we're
we're showering in the same spot you
know everyone's it took all Community
you know so this ability to have this
relationship with so many people is is
been a great part of my life and I think
my ability to relate to them care about
them they felt like well if top why why
should Tom care about me and I'm like
dude because you're my teammate I know
Tom but you've already won six Super
Bowls I'm like I don't give it
like we have this year
this is a year my first year in Tampa I
don't care what I did like that's I look
at those things one day and that's great
someone's gonna say it but this is the
moment right now let's get let's get to
work let's you know let's get to know
who you are let's get to mobile let's
make the most out of your career look my
career is great like but I want the best
for your career too and if it's going to
be your best career you need me to be
good and I need you to be good so let's
work together because every year those
things change
was it was it uh
you know how uh uh you get a person that
comes in and you sell them on the
culture here's what we're all about so a
leader I'm going to sell you here's why
we do this here's why you accept high
standards here's why you get up and do
you here's why you watch the tape here's
why you take care of your health here's
why because if we do this at the end of
the season we got a chance at winning a
championship and being the best okay or
is it more the peer pressure of the
culture you either fit the culture or
you're not going to want to be around
this culture so you filter yourself out
which was more the model at specifically
more under below check and yourself in
New England was it more selling the
culture to the player or was it more no
man this is our culture either adjust or
I'm sorry it's not going to work out I I
think it's a great question and it's
like it's it's hard to develop culture
right because that's a word that's
thrown around a lot and I think that's
has to do with like values of the
company but in the end what does culture
mean to me do we care about each other
and do we care about what we're trying
to accomplish
most people just care about themselves
and you just care about your own
personal situation my co-worker what the
mission is what the
not the owner usually doesn't think like
that because this is his business but
the more you give people the opportunity
to have ownership of that culture the
better and I was in the I look at some
great cultures over the years like you
know sports are kind of easy you know
somewhat easier but even like the
culture of like you know and the the
aren't the the Armed Forces our military
you know like you look show up to the
Naval Academy like man that's a culture
like and people are accountable to that
they show up every day they show up on
time they respect each other everyone's
probably got different tenants that they
believe in but the fundamental belief is
I'm giving myself to something greater
than myself
I'm giving myself something greater than
me as an individual because it's going
to pay off in ways that nothing in life
can be accomplished in a big way without
teamwork
teamwork is what it's all about you show
up every day you play your role you do
your best and then you communicate about
it and then you have people that hold
you accountable to the results and if
the results aren't good enough then you
re-strategize or you get rid of some
people and you move on so I think what
we do what we are fortunate enough to
develop over an early period of time in
New England was a culture of a lot of
teammates that may not have been the
best like myself but we cared a lot
we worked really hard we were really
coachable and we won and then some other
players are like dude that's what I want
I want to win they joined our program so
then we had which is really important
you need people that drive the culture
because it just can't be you because
when you turn your back to focus on what
you got to do you need other people
driving the culture too and we developed
a culture of culture drivers Willie
McGinnis
Teddy brewski Mike Vrabel Troy Brown Wes
Welker Kevin Faulk Matt Light all these
guys that they just it was inherent to
what the team ultimately ended up
becoming we all drove the culture and
then no one was gonna it up so you
got some people that came in from other
places and man they might have had maybe
some a certain reputation and they
realized that when they got in that
locker room
I can't make bad decisions here
there's no room for bad decisions in
this place not not that we were all like
Angels or nothing we weren't but we
weren't destructive to what the culture
was and those guys who were they didn't
last long and they realized pretty
quickly they didn't fit in
and they moved on somewhere else and my
view was always like man if if you're
about yourself you may be amazing I
would love to compete against you
go play for the other team because when
you're around a bunch of selfish people
and I've been around those yep you know
guys that the you win the game and
they're pissed off because they didn't
get the ball as much as they wanted and
you're like there's one ball I'm trying
my best I'm trying to do what's best for
the team like yeah I I there's a lot of
other good players here some days it's
going to be your week other days it's
not but what are we in this for are we
in here to pad your statistics whether
that's because we all get accolades for
those and we have you know people that
want to see us succeed but in my view
the team's success was always most
important and I think the great reward
in my life is not
the record that you would read off
before I came on stage what you said was
your teammates loved you that's the
greatest reward I could ever have it's
I'm telling you when we have the guys
there at please when we had the geyser
at Foxboro and for me sometimes if you
want to learn about me ask the people
that work with me you're going to learn
more if I want to learn about you of
course I can do an interview with you
and you'll give the answers you'll give
and you're maybe not wanting to offend
anybody so you kind of now at a
different phase of your life but if I
talk to your teammates again like oh man
listen here's how he was here's this
everybody talked very highly but let's
let's stay on this so
driver for you what drove you more
because you just said something if
you're selfish hey man congratulations
on you being great I cannot wait to
compete against you right straight up to
your face okay
what drove you more did words of what
other people said about you in the paper
media drive you kind of like Ted
Williams was driven by that did hey Tom
Brady is done you know Max Kellerman
every freaking season now he's done he's
done he's done is it more Peyton
Manning's the better quarterback between
the two and it's just kind of like you
know Joe Montana just yesterday said
well the greatest quarterback of all
time is Dan Marino we all know that is
not me it's not it's time okay did that
drive you you know is it more you know
the people who left you they're like hey
man it's great it's been a great run but
I'm gonna go play with XYZ Tim I'm gonna
go play with it so you think that guy's
a better teammate to go or is it people
from other sports that they're like hey
man the greatest of all time the goat I
mean listen everybody says he's the MJ
he's the Jordan of this he's the Jordan
of this and why are they saying he's the
joke why don't I say he's the Brady of
this he's the Brady I want to change and
I don't know if you're going to be you
know fully comfortable to serve because
some of these guys are your relationship
your friends which one drove you the
most behind closed doors
I think that the point is like the
attachment of someone else's thoughts
about me
didn't
they did one percent
and here I was I was a little bit older
but I was still pretty decent as a
player and uh I was like all right free
agencies coming
and I called my agent and I was like all
right what's the deal like what are we
thinking he went off a list of teams
right and there was probably like
seven or eight teams and in my mind I'm
like seven or eight teams like there
should be like
20 teams like they're you're telling me
there's like that many better
quarterbacks than me or and obviously
the situations fit certain ways but it
came down to like there was a couple
teams that like you can be motivated by
more than one percent but I'm saying you
could be motivated by a newspaper
article or talk show debate or by people
saying Peyton Manning I got better like
but at the end of the day I don't think
that motivates you every day I just
don't I don't think you wake up every
day super motivated to go read the
newspaper I think you wake up every day
and hopefully you can look at yourself
and say
did I give it my best
was that my best did I give it
everything I could did the people around
me get as much as I could and that the
answer is no that's okay like that's
okay like but just at least you know it
but don't think that like you know that
you're gonna have a lot of success if
you all you do is care about yourself
you don't work that hard no one's that
accountable look I I I was on a team
that was last year in Tampa it was tough
when I see a defense sack the
quarterback
and every D line then runs up to the guy
who sacks a quarterback and they do a
group celebration I go oh and I don't
want to play again but then I see one
guy sack the quarterback and he's got
his ninth celebration and you know and
none of his teammates celebrate with
them I'm like well he's in it for
himself
you know that's not gonna be that's not
gonna go well over a period of time so
these are just things you guys can see
now you know with just a little
awareness like who are the dangerous
companies who are the dangerous you know
teams and competition that you guys are
facing when you guys succeed is it all
about that person is it about the team's
success I always felt like the
quarterback's job is when it doesn't go
well you take the blame when it goes
well you give the credit that's what
great leaders do you know you always
that's how it should be in
in all those Sports by the way Sam Kelly
Mario can one of you guys find my phone
and bring it to me I don't have the time
so I don't know what time it is one of
you guys can find my phone Tom question
uh uh we have you have you watched a
movie The Last Dance have you watched
yeah I loved it so a couple questions
for you uh one uh uh the moment with
Isaiah and Jordan okay and I see you as
a guy that you kind of you you you maybe
you watch the competition and everybody
else can be I've seen your shot your
turnaround shot you got a good game as
well you're an athlete you know you're a
guy that kind of follows uh along with
what's going on everywhere
the moment of Isaiah not shaking his
hand when they lost
and they walk off Bill and beer and
Michael's like you kidding me I lost you
last year humiliated I came and she'll
call your hands one by one by one and I
said hey go win the championship I go on
the gym come back train we beat you you
don't want to even give me that respect
no problem
and Michael was a grudge guy yeah okay
and then Dream Team boom doesn't let him
get back on the team and well it was
never Michael it was never this okay
well it was Michael let's just say and
then come to the Celebration that
happened last year a few months ago
where all the top 75 NBA players are
there there's there's this one scene
that's gone viral on Tick Tock I don't
know if you know which I haven't seen it
now there's one scene that's gone viral
it's freaking hilarious yeah where you
see magic is there shaking hands with
Isaiah
and Michael standing behind magic okay
and uh Magic's like yeah yeah all this
stuff all this stuff and then Isaiah
walks off and you see Michael comes and
he whispers something in Magic's ear and
this is within seconds after he talks to
Isaiah and they are both laughing so
hard yeah right now a couple trolls
added additional sound to say what would
have been said I'm gonna show you
afterwards it's unbelievably funny yeah
did you in your career
ever have an Isaiah Thomas
I I could hold a grudge as good as any
of them out there actually I uh that
that was good aspects of of I would say
the motivation like you know I
it's it's very different like I didn't
have any friends on the other teams I
didn't you know and I think it's a
little different day and age yeah I
didn't I wasn't X teammates I left well
yeah to a degree but I mean I was my
friends were the guys that were in the
battle with me so it's very different in
today's age which I actually think is a
little
uh
you've got to create
a lot of different emotion to to
heighten your sense of awareness and
focus like for me anger was good anger
was good because it was motivating the
more I could create an enemy the more I
want to go out and kill those guys now I
knew I wasn't going to kill them
physically
but man if I could just
what did they say you know and what did
they look like do they disrespect me at
all you know and did that so say
something
like those are little little little
things that can get me right in the
emotional frame of mind that when I ran
on the field and I said let's go
it was really let's go kick some ass
that's what we were doing
so
there wasn't a lot of smiley faces with
me out there there wasn't a lot of
smiley faces with Michael Jordan there
weren't a lot of smiley faces with Kobe
Bryant there weren't a lot of smiley
faces with Tiger Woods
right tiger wasn't trying to be friends
with anybody tiger had no friends
Tiger's friends were guys that he knew
he could kick their butt those were
Tiger's friends
and they were very happy to have their
butts kicked by Tiger Wood to be his
friend the tiger had him right where he
wanted them and I think for me like even
when I watched sports today and I see
like golf's a good example I see these
guys on the Range yeah like they're all
buddies and their caddies are friends
and I'm like that's not the Killer
Instinct that's just not I don't I don't
know how you can wanna crush the
competition because they are your
competition but then they're like have
dinner with them the next night now I
had a few friends like because maybe it
was a long period of time but I could
count on one hand the number of
maybe Peyton Manning and I and I love
Peyton maybe I've had dinner with him
twice
in 23 years and it's not because I don't
love them I really do twice in 20 years
probably three years and you know our
competition was always like
I looked up to him so much I admired
Peyton Manning like I I loved his game I
loved everything he did but
if if we wanted to get where we wanted
to go we had to get through them
so I had to create something different
in my mind he couldn't be my friend
you know when I see that with
a lot of the guys that you know Drew
Brees I love Drew he was incredible but
he wasn't my friend now he's my friend
because I'm not competing them against
anymore and I just think it's different
now because of social media the ability
to connect with everybody everyone's
friends now in sports all the time and
I'm like I don't get that
that's just not my thing so and it's not
that like I'm trying to be a jerk but in
my job it's different than my person you
know my
it's it's interesting like when I was a
quarterback I was just playing
quarterback yeah it was me the person
but it was it was me the quarterback
that was out there because I was doing a
job I wasn't the father I wasn't the dad
out there I wasn't you know the husband
out there I was the quarterback out
there on the field I was the quarterback
when I went to work nothing was going to
get in the way of that you know and then
when I stepped off the field great I'm
back to who I am I had to draw on a part
of me that was emotional yeah aggressive
angry decisive sick irrational
all those things and then when I came
back into life you know okay well like
calm down you know so
but I would say a lot of the guys that I
looked up to approached it the same way
you know I don't think Jack Nicklaus was
trying to be friends with anybody I
don't think Joe Montana was trying to be
friends with anybody I don't think a lot
of I don't think Muhammad Ali or Mike
Tyson were trying to be friends with
anybody I think they were going out
there on a mission and if there was
someone in their way they had to crush
him question let me follow up so you
said Peyton Manning to me Peyton Manning
is a competitor it's like Michael Clyde
Michael Barkley Michael you know it's
like a magic fine but you know it was
like no you know the whole game in the
Olympics whatever game it was where
Michael and Magic what do you call Magic
and bird team up to play that video
that's about four minutes and 30 seconds
and you see it says listen I'm the guy
there's a new Chief in town right and it
was like and like listen Larry says
magic relax we're not at this guy's
level he's better than us right I'm not
talking about competition I'm talking
about who disrespected you because
Isaiah disrespected Michael yeah did
anybody disrespect you disrespect you
that you said it's done
I would say there were I can't think of
any competitors off the top of my head
coaches like I like the guys that would
like you know
and I remember a few instances like you
guys remember in Dominican Sue of course
okay
and he ended up being a teammate thank
God because
ndamakin was one of the biggest fastest
most explosive athletes the league has
ever seen and the Dolphins signed them
to like a 20 million dollar a year
contract highest paid defender in
history and they were in a division so
we see him twice a year and he had a
reputation that you know he was played
to the echo of the whistle
and uh
I would always try to butter the D
lineman up because I didn't want them
like trying to hit me any harder than
they already were trying to hit me like
they get paid a lot more the more they
kick my ass which that's good incentive
for them so every opportunity I could
get I would try to like you're a great
player man like stay out of my backfield
you know like man like damn you really
hit me hard on that one you know
so in Dominican one time we were playing
in Miami and he had been in the
backfield like a couple plays in the
game and I can feel it because I let go
of the ball and then this heavy disarm
would come in and just boom and I'm not
that big I mean he's and when he hits
you it's like different than everyone
else hitting you and I never wanted to
show him that like God damn that hurt
so he got me a couple times early so I
was like the second Drive of the game
and we were driving the ball and I let I
one two three four five I dropped and I
threw the ball and just as I threw it
boom he hit me again and I'm like how
did he get here that quick
so I slapped them on the butt
and I go dude stay out of our
backfield today and he looked at me goes
I'm not your friend
and I was like I respect that I respect
that
I never said another word to him
and he became my teammate a few years
later and I you know I love being his
teammate but look he didn't give that
you know I'm won this or won that or had
this or that and there were a lot of
guys that were you know a lot of guys
would come up to me and they'd be like
hey man it's an honor to be on the field
with you and I was like oh thanks man I
appreciate it in my mind I'm thinking
they're done
here we go it's gonna be easy today's
gonna be easy so uh Tom I have to ask
this question from you so uh um
six championships okay you got six rings
so from a fans perspective and we've had
this debate with friends just to kind of
see which one it is what drove you more
was it to get one more than Belichick or
one more than Michael
it was neither
I promise you I promise you it wasn't it
was I I when I really doubled down on my
health and wellness in about 2013 with
Alex who I referred to earlier and I
said I said in my when I turned 30 I
want to play till I'm 40.
and I started improving my 30s which
that doesn't really happen for athletes
because I really started to work on all
the things that were making me
successful physically I only trained
doing the things that really worked I my
nutrition got better my hydration got
better all the pliability of treatments
I got better and he and I would joke
dude like this is unbelievable I'm
getting faster my arm's getting better I
learn better techniques a new Mentor
came into my life Tom house is another
great throwing coach I learned a lot
from him
I had all these years with Belichick
mentally I knew what to do physically I
was improving emotionally I was at a
great Point like why can't I continue to
go and I just thought man I'm gonna play
10 more years and when I was 35 I was
like
I feel better at 35 than I did at 30.
like I still got another 10 years in me
and I literally committed I got 10 more
years and
I said I'm going to play till I'm 45
years old and last year I was 45 years
old and playing so what it's not about
like for me the
when I made that decision at 35 it
wasn't I'm gonna play until I win Seven
Super Bowls I never once said that we
won the fifth against Atlanta which was
unbelievable
unbelievable like that that game my
teammates like that was sick that was
incredible I still watch that and I'm
like that it was I mean I'm glad I was
playing because I had a heart attack if
I was watching
and then 2017 we actually had like
probably a better chance to win and we
lost to the Eagles in the Super Bowl and
we played a great game we just look we I
played great I just we didn't win then
2018 we freaking found a way to beat the
Rams through a lot of good process a lot
of good we weren't the most talented
team in 2018. we were we won on process
we won on culture yeah our culture
drivers led us to succeed we went
through work ethic we went through a lot
of intangibles and then I went to Tampa
in 2020 and you know we
we put together a great group of players
teammates everyone was super focused
that year and then I I just think
winning Super Bowls was the result of a
lot of great process like my view is
like you can't control the outcome all
the time right like the ball's gonna
bounce the other team's way like Duke
cut the ball in his helmet in
2007. that would have been the greatest
team ever and that's like one that still
gets me yep because we had a great team
that year and the dude caught the bonus
helmet with one of the greatest player
ever played against on his back
sometimes it should go the other
people's way it shouldn't always go your
way so you get motivated by the losses
you stay motivated through the winning
what you can control is your process you
can control those intangibles you can
control the work ethic the consistent
discipline your attitude your culture
how much you care all those things are
in you they just need to be drawn out of
you and really when you're in that
position that you feel like you're gotta
got those pretty well under control then
you start passing those on to the other
people that you're working with that are
parts of your team because I don't care
how good any one of you are sitting out
there it doesn't matter unless you got a
great team around you you know you could
be great you probably are great you need
a lot of other great people to support
you Tom and I and I
absolutely
I appreciate the answer it's awesome
it's great but I'm selfish and greedy
man I gotta push back let me tell you
why okay
so
I I you know I'm writing a book right
now it's going to come out December 5th
it's not out it's going to come out like
four or five months it's called choose
your enemies wisely I think you've
chosen your enemies wisely because I
think for me if I I'm driven by enemies
I don't even I can't even describe it to
you like I have a list of all the quotes
everything they said what they looked at
I mean my names are for me I know what
I'm driving at this point in my life and
then you graduate enemies and you say
good things about them and go find new
ones and then boom new ones boom new
ones right okay
so
let's say that's really the reason
let's let's let's buy into them we're
going to be skeptical as fans and we'll
have our beers and talk and say I don't
agree I agree we'll do our part right
because you're the guy
we're on the other side
I don't know I if you're if you're gonna
do that then you would have stayed with
a team and you would have wrapped it up
there Robert Kraft is willing to give
you a one day contract I think he said
it this year May 23rd to come back
Patriots I want to do the ceremony which
freaking is going to be sick of course
whether he's joking or whatever it's
just being playful about it you know he
loves you the way he looks at you he's
got so much love for you but you come
back and you get your seventh just like
you said maybe one percent the media
drove you which one of the two drove you
more even if it's by one percent or half
a percent is it having more one more
than Michael or Belichick
I gotta ask you bro you're killing me
even if it's half a percent yeah uh
I would rather have one than lost
uh
and I'd rather have seven and six I get
it but if coach Belichick was to win a
Super Bowl this year I don't think it
takes anything away from me
I think it only adds to it how great he
is like I have a great appreciation for
him
because without him I'm not sitting here
today
so like he wasn't my competition he was
my competition when I played against him
that one game
and we won
but
he wasn't like I I genuinely root for it
for them I really do like
I think every once in a while maybe you
guys have seen little Snippets of me
that look I do I have a little Grudge
from time to time and I think that's
totally fine I think emotion you know
maximizing and optimizing our potential
is physical mental and emotional I
believe that physically I was able to
mentally emotionally there's little
triggers absolutely all the time some
opponent says something in check they
really don't want me a high so check oh
that was a six round pick check all
those little things add up but I still
the man in the glass that's the one that
motivated me he's the guy I was
accountable to nothing that anyone did
took away from me
the only person that could take away
from me is me
so can I give you my interpretation of
that answer please okay
by the way and this is my interpret I
speak sign language right so I'm trying
to kind of read in between the lines the
way I take it is it felt good beating
them straight up the one game that you
played but in my mind based on what you
just said
having one more than Michael is more
important than having one more than
Belichick that's how I process what you
just said is that fair is that fearful
can I live with that can you uh
I love Michael Jordan as God literally
there's no athlete
so Michael is like if if there's your
kids you know and that throw I don't
know how they feel about me I think
today they love you they love Michael
Jordan was my he everyone wanted to be
like Mike so like I even when I see Mike
today I'm still like that's
Michael Jordan right there you know
and I just think he's the coolest guy
and and you know I loved his
determination I love you know I see like
what Messi's doing here in Miami like
unbelievable like I see Cristiano
Ronaldo I I admire athletes as much as
as much as anybody else I especially the
guys that I really uh you know it's like
there's some guys that are athletes
athletes
you know and when I see some of those
guys those are the guys that I love you
know like I was in I went to a preseason
game that day and I saw Steve Smith he's
he was the receiver sick for Baltimore
and I've love Steve Smith yeah
because he he wanted to kill the
defensive back 89 right 89 yeah and he
was a little dude but played with the
biggest heart and I would have loved to
play with Steve Smith and Julian Edelman
and I you know these guys like there's a
lot of guys that are primadonas you know
they they were the prodigies it just
came easy for them you know like I don't
think it came easy for Michael Jordan as
great as he was you know LeBron's been
through a lot it it's tough for LeBron
like and he's unbelievable you know so I
love Steph Curry like these are the guys
that I look up to and I and I look they
inspire me you know in the same way so
I'm looking to be inspired too just like
you guys are looking to be inspired I'm
looking to be inspired too and I draw on
a lot of people that are teaching me
different things too so I can't even
speak because of you so I came here
because I love what you're doing with
people I love how you're trying to
impact the world in a positive thank you
thank you Tom appreciate you so uh means
a lot thank you but I got a gift for you
I got a gift for you we put almost a
thousand hours into this gift okay based
on some of your answers I think you're
gonna love this gift I don't know what
kind of reaction I want to get from you
you have no idea how much I've been
thinking about it all night saying I
hope this guy falls in love with this
gift as much as I freaking love this
gift to give to you but before we give
the gift I do want to go through we
order these supplements for everybody
these are their protein bars did you
guys everybody should have one of these
on their uh what do you call it on there
we got 3 000 of these for you so a few
things so for you when it comes down to
your health if we can talk about tb12s
everybody knows and they can go to the
website we'll put that in the video as
well so a few things you one you sleep
at 8 30. two buy your ceramic sleepwear
right recovery pajamas okay no tomatoes
no strawberries no eggplant flotation
therapy two gallons of water a day
breakfast 36 ounces of protein 80 vegan
20 organic meat if you eat chocolate is
a square
of chocolate and it's a specific kind of
chocolate right it's a cacao or
something like that chocolate yeah the
dark chocolate that you eat man like how
much was this and this the reason why
you were able to play as long as that
you did yeah huge I mean hugely
important it's like
you know everyone
like I said this is I was trying to
treat my body like a Ferrari like an F1
car you know you just can't put little
crappy tires on there and you know
figure out how much gas you got like I
always wanted a lot of gas in the tank
especially as I got older because it got
challenging for us you know we're not
young we don't you know have the same
you know biology in our in our 40s or
30s that we did in our in our teens in
our 20s so I had to really lock in on my
routine over a period of time and I
think that a lot of that didn't happen
overnight like I started with my body
Coach Alex and started taking some like
just nutritional supplements and then
when I got good at that I started doing
a lot of pliability work making sure
that all my muscles were long and
unrestricted then I started to go okay
well the only way to improve our
treatments through long and unrestricted
you know uh movements with my muscles is
to hydrate them you know do you want
your muscles to look like beef jerky or
do you want your muscles to look like
beef tenderloin should they be really
moist and hydrated so they can move
that's the only way to absorb the forces
on the field great let's let's stay
really hydrated oh great we cause a lot
of inflammation in our bodies through
workouts through playing football games
through practicing through throwing
passes how do I reduce inflammation I
gotta eliminate some foods that cause
inflammation strawberries eggplant all
the night shades to Tomatoes things that
we refer to so a lot of those things
took 12 15 years to really manifest
himself in total but I approached it in
a in a in a very holistic way you know I
it wasn't like hey I do all these things
at one time it was let's just start slow
you know and then work over time to
improve you know this process of my body
and what I needed to do in order for it
to go out there every day and compete
with guys that were half my age so all
those things that you did were just
little routines that built up and like
anything the routine I had in high
school that worked for me so I wanted to
improve it in college I wasn't gonna go
oh I made it now I'm I'm actually a
starter let's go back to sleeping into
nine o'clock not studying my film eating
like crap not caring about my teammates
no it was like let's do more of that and
then I got to the pros and it was like
what should I have done oh let's compete
a little less care a little less you
know now that I'm professional no it was
like let's double down on that so when
it came to my health and wellness it was
more of that oh hydrating works that I
felt a lot better I don't feel like I
had any really soft tissue injuries I
could go out there and play a full
season let's do more hydration oh my
diet's getting better I like the way my
body's shaping up let's do more of that
great oh my God I'm working out and I'm
not as sore let's do more treatments you
know so a lot of those things were just
me
trying to be open to the people that
came into my life to say hey man you
know better than me so let me learn from
you and let me try to take those things
and incorporate them over you know this
this you know first half of my life what
what a great brand by the tb12 what a
great name for Brian make so no he's Tom
Brady yeah okay Tom I want you to face
this way if you want to stand up I want
you to look this way okay I never turn
my back on a crowd somebody tend to come
hit me back there Allen to get camera of
angle from their a b-roll angle from
their Allen if you can come Maverick get
it from that angle as well I don't I
don't want you to look yet Tom I don't
want you I can't fit that in my car on
the way home you know we're gonna
deliver this to you so I I want to okay
so we sat there and we said I wanted to
put a painting together and we made a
list of all the things that I think
moves you memories uh family moments
you've had all of those things in one
painting I went and called my friend
brentell who's done a painting for me
he's on a pen for Mark Cuban and then we
started working on this wow and it was
phase one phase two phase three phase
four phase five no we gotta fix it we
gotta do this we got to do that
constantly going back and forth back and
forth back and forth until we finally
got this so if you don't mind coming
don't take it off yet because I want I
want him to see you and Oliver come I
want to see the audience react first
then you see it if you don't mind
looking this way first okay okay go
ahead take it I can start crying I'm
gonna take it down take it you cannot
put it all down go for it put it all
down yeah go for before I tell Tom to
come then okay hang on
okay Tom I want you to look at this can
I look yes
tell me if you like this oh man so can I
explain
[Applause]
wow this is obviously
family we know what game this is wow
this is you all your rings your favorite
teammates the legendary picture here you
draft 199 Michigan your mom your dad you
your kid we created this Mount Rushmore
with yourself Michael Tiger Woods Messi
and then we got the Tampa side all of
this gift for you so when you look at
this it reminds you of what you've done
with the first half of your life man wow
this is hopefully a gift you appreciate
from us to you thank you thank you
anytime man oh man thank you all right
thank you unbelievable yes thank you
unbelievable
that's spectacular thank you anytime any
final words to the crowd before we wrap
up yeah let's do a quick picture here
yeah let's do a quick picture here where
you want me anyway
go for it
[Applause]
Tom any final thoughts yeah
obviously it's a pleasure to be here
with you guys today and
I think for me it's always uh you know I
I I still think of myself as a kid
growing up in the Bay Area like on
Portola drive and and to have you guys
come out and obviously be a part of this
event with Patrick
um it's honor for me to be here and I'm
happy that I could share a few things
with you guys that could inspire you
guys to dig a little bit deeper to learn
a few things that you could take back
with you and your everyday life to try
to maximize your potential and take
advantage of the opportunities that you
get and we're not victims of this life
you know we we wake up every day with
choices to make and you get a choice
every day and like I said earlier I
think whether or not you're going to
look back on your life as a success is
going to be determined by what your
values and priorities are and how often
you're willing to wake up every day and
make the choices that are going to
fulfill you and bring you the joy that
you're looking for so this is a great
Step In the Journey it's an honor to be
with you guys and hopefully we can do it
again sometime thank you give it up
everybody
[Music]
so I'm curious now you've seen the whole
thing what do you think was more
important to get the seven drink was it
more I can do one on my own or was it
more about Jordan being the goat of
goats I want to hear your thoughts but
you know a lot of times I get asked
questions about how you prepare for
interviews like this number one it makes
it very easy when you're very interested
in the person you're sitting down with I
am very interested in the guy we just
sat down which is Tom Brady my entire
family had to read man in the arena and
write a paper on it my 10 year old and
my eight-year-old son at the time
they're not 11 and 9. we rented at
Foxboro to go out there and take 96 of
our sales Executives and watch men in
the arena for two days and bring out a
couple of times teammates and his
manager for them to ask him as much
questions and then during the break
they're eating food and they're on Fox
we're watching The Stadium just mentally
emotionally getting to that place but
you know if you think about preparing
for this interview so if you're asking
that question the way I prepare for
these interviews is I like facts I like
history I like watching a bunch of
content which I watch a lot of different
things on him then I like things I'm
interested in angles topics our research
team does a phenomenal job back in the
days when I was doing interviews we
didn't have a research team so I was the
research person but you can hire Fiverr
in a lot of different ways to do it so
it was a great experience sitting down
with them I hope you enjoyed it as much
as I did I would say a lot of times
people want to ask me questions to say
Pat how do you do this how do you do
that we launched an app recently called
minute and the whole purpose of this app
connect is many times you'll DM a lot of
different people and they don't respond
and the reason why they don't respond is
because they got a thousand DMS they
can't just respond to everybody but you
want to get an answer back so what if
there was a platform where you could pay
to get a respond back for a DM with a
video or a FaceTime call with the
individual that's exactly why we
launched the app connect do you have a
minute to connect let's connect so
whether you want to connect with me and
ask me a question about the Tom Brady
interview or any other expert that's on
manect click on the link below to
download the app and start connecting
now
foreign
[Music]